[Music]
how are you guys doing recently Ben
shipo has come to the United
Kingdom has come to London to Cambridge
to Oxford he come to places where
hundreds of thousands of pro Palestinian
Marchers and people of the resistance
have come out in the streets from
different backgrounds from different
races and from different religions to
show solidarity in the cause which is a
pro Palestinian cause an anti-oppression
cause a Just Cause And this individual
Ben shipiro who's known who I am for a
very long time and who's tried to engage
means scurrying along from time to time
and who's used as an intellectual human
shield John Jordan Peterson and Piers
Morgan and other people to try and avoid
dealing with me directly this is
individual in his usual manner in his
usual
manner has gone to engage the
undergrads the college
students yes and in fact those college
students dealt with him in a manner
which gave him a run for his money left
him on the ropes mashallah some of the
Muslim sisters and some of the other
people
there were giving some fantastic points
which he didn't even know how to respond
to one I'm going to do now is just
respond to a couple of those
clips and show you the ignorance of this
man on a topic which we would think he
would know more about considering the
emotional the monetary investment that
he has made to it let's take a look at
the first clip what response do you have
about the great March of return which is
a very well-documented incident where
peacefully Palestinian civilians just
marched Cho their own land that they
they have a right to go and return to
but they were killed shot at and
murdered in Cold Blood what year are we
talking about which group are we talking
about I need more specificity I'm
talking about the great March of return
I know I'm asking for more specificity
because I'm unaware of all the details
of what you're speaking about so the
great March of return is a
well-documented instance where many
Palestinians after a tweet by a
Palestinian encouraged other
Palestinians to go March peacefully back
to their land which land is theirs what
are we talking about talking about
occupied Palestine are you talking about
in proper Israel where are we talking
about like which areas we're talking
about on the we're talking about on the
borders of Palestine and we're also
talking about their right to return to
pales there is no right to return if
you're talking about in Palestine if
you're talking about the land that is
inside the 67 borders there is no right
of return TOA there's no right of return
to Tel Aviv there's no right of return
to West Jerusalem the great March of
return that was being referenced by the
sister was in fact in Gaza that's where
it was now if you know anything about
recent Israeli or Palestinian politics
which I would think you should having
115 employees in Daily wire hundreds of
millions not if not billions of pounds
or dollars being spent on the matter
that one of your researchers would have
told you actually about this
situation it was in Gaza and it was a
situation where
223 Palestinians were shot dead by the
IDF and this was without a single rocket
being launched by Hamas or a single shot
being fired this happened in the Years
2018 to
2019 now you imagine this is the thing
that is under reported if not not
reported by the Western media and then
you start asking the question as to why
or what happened or when should the
clock start and you conveniently start
the clock on the 7th of October because
that's when Jewish life was affected and
we've already spoken about the tragic
nature of Civilian death whether it be
Jewish life black man's life white man's
life yellow man's life any man's life
we've already spoken about that at
length but why I'm going to say to you
is the fact that you didn't even know
about that this happened in Gaza well I
know full well that if
223 Jewish people died you'd know about
that you'd know the date you'd know the
names of the people you would know the
names and in fact the aftermath of that
particular
situation showed you the futility of
international law for you see what
happened after that was that the
Palestinian Liberation Organization or
the PA I should say the Palestinian
Authority they raised the matter to the
ICC the international criminal court as
you may know there is the icj and the IC
both of them are international courts
when this matter was raised to the
international criminal court that Trump
that then Trump
Administration issued an executive
order that threatened to freeze the
assets of the international criminal
court which had the overall
effect of the Palestinians rights being
curtailed meaning what meaning this
meaning the people of Gaza before the
situation took place in
2023 they were attempting peaceful means
to try and get their voice heard by the
International
Community and even in those peaceful
means just like we saw in the Ina and
other things before it the cruel and the
terroristic IDF killed Palestinian
civilians 223 of them so much so that
human rights organizations detailed this
in great detail this matter the fact
that you didn't even know what happened
with the great March you didn't even
know it we saw it in the clip you had no
idea that this happened you had no idea
you're ignorant of the situation number
one ha you're ignorant of your own
politics in the region that you claim to
represent number two that you didn't
even know the aftermath you didn't know
where where happened any of those
details you have you ignorant of the
situation shows me full well that only
Jewish life matters to people like you
that's the truth you are a Zionist and
and a ethnic supremacist clearly because
you can't bring
it to condemn the killing of Palestinian
civilians by the IDF Hamas Hamas
Hamas this cannot be the only scapegoat
because as I mentioned Hamas did not
shoot nor uh launch a ET at that
time so this is the first thing I
mention the second thing I'll mention
relating to the clip the sister was
talking
about the right of return and then he
mentioned that well can you have people
going into a Sovereign Nation and quote
unquote set up shop that's what he
said set up shop who are the indigenous
who are the indigenous people of that
particular land are you claiming Shapiro
that the only ha I'm not even denying
that Jewish people may have been
indigenous to the land my question is
are the only IND is your claim that the
only indigenous people in that
land are Jewish people is that the
claim Y in all the time for thousand
from Millennia could it not be said that
one single Arab Palestinian was
indigenous to that is that your claim so
that's my first point the second point
is which is the argument that you don't
understand but I will make it clear for
you and easy for you huh and your other
people to know your zist friends
because yeah you will all understand
this argument is is is the is the thorn
in your racist sides cuz we we know
you're a racist what you said about Arab
people you agreed with a quote and I've
got it already saved that said that they
are 100% terrorist sympathizers or thugs
terrorist sympathizers or thugs that
Jews like to build things Arabs like to
bomb crap and you've already admitted
that you said that had you said that
about black people you'd be finished if
I said that about Jews I'd be canceled
but you can say it about Arabic people
because as you
think you can say that about
Palestinians because as you think the
blood and the sanctity and the value of
the Palestinian person has become the
cheapest frankly but let me continue
anyway because the
aparte yes
aparte right of return law indicates
without shadow of a
doubt that Israel is an apartheid state
it has racial
preferencing what's the evidence of that
the evidence of that is as follows
number one what is aarte or what are the
thresholds that must be met met in order
for an aparte to happen the thresholds
that must be met in order for an aparte
to happen is that there discrimination
based on race and we know that
jewishness is both ethnic and religious
both at the same time but the right of
return law only favors Jewish people in
other words no Arabs can come to that
land which means to say that the right
of return law fulfills the Criterion
required for an apartheid state to be
labeled as
such the point is is that the right of
return law is a racist law and the fact
that you can't understand that and that
you defend that law and that you can't
condemn that law is ample evidence that
you my friend and I use that term
actually I don't you retract that term
you're not my friend you boy yeah are a
racist you are a
racist
I wonder where you get this
from because before I say this I will
say
this you cannot support apartheid laws
and right of return laws without the
prerequisite of being a racist that's
why I claim you support apartheid laws
therefore you fulfill the prerequisites
of being a racist you are a racist
there's ample evidence that you are a
racist whoever is associated with you
doesn't condemn you doesn't put you in
your place then maybe they are racist
too or they're afraid of being labeled
as anti-mite well now they're going to
be labeled as racist or racist
sympathizer because you're a racist
you're a
racist and we've seen the horrible
racism that has taken place in in the
state of Israel not just against Arab
people who are Muslims and Christians by
the way but by the safam safic Jews by
the ashkanazi and by the Ethiopians and
by the sudanes and buy this one and buy
that one and you can just
read yes newspaper articles on the
matter even the left has understood that
in Israel that there is this racism and
you're part of
that so don't you
dare try try it speak with confidence
come and speak to Muslim sisters that
sister was completely correct just like
people after the that
sister were correct as well
when they were making the historical
case and I noticed that you're a liar
when it comes to
History either you are ignorant of
History just like you're ignorant of
this or you're a
liar and of course if you want to see
more information about the historical
development I have done a video with
Abdullah and delusi about that about the
entire concise history of Palestine
conflict with that I will conclude and
I'll say to Ben I know you're watching
me I know you're afraid of
me I know you are I would be too if I
were
you it would make sense here is a man
who can destroy me intellectually and
physically in a legal manner here is a
man who is more than me in every way
here is a man who when I saw a image of
him and a video of him on P Mogan
show I
done I swallowed
deeply and I'm not going to make any
jokes about that I saw there was a gulp
that
happened here is a
man that if he delivers one
slap intellectual slap that I would drop
on the floor quicker then the IDF drops
bombs on
babies I understand why you're not
engaging me I just want to speak to your
wife for a second yes I'm speaking to
Ben's wife Ben's wife whatever your name
is just know your husband is a
coward just know this is the real man
look at me Ben's wife please look at me
this is the your husband is a coward he
can't engage me and he has no excuse he
can't excuse
himself by saying he's more qualified
than I am more famous than I am gets
more numbers than I am H have or
anything but he can't engage me and if
he's got any children Ben's children I
want you to
know that I would never wish for you
what I'm seeing in Gaza with the
Palestinian
children